será difícil que carlos consiga
equiparar su figura a la de su madre
pero cuáles serán los principales retos
para carlos tercero dio pistas en su
discurso sobre lo que se pueda esperar
en su reinado
bueno primero que todo muchas gracias
por la invitación rodrigo y si tienen
razón van a haber grandes obstáculos y
grandes pruebas que va a tener que
superar el monarca del reino unido
partiendo principalmente con el hecho de
que la vara ha quedado bastante alta
a eso yo le sumaría también otros
elementos no en estos momentos la
situación política económica y social
quizás el reino unido no es la más
halagüeña particularmente porque se ve
en nubarrones de precesión en el futuro
y por lo tanto la casa real va a tener
que ser lo más austera posible y
predicar con el ejemplo en momentos que
van a ser particularmente duros para la
para la población del reino y por otro
lado también está todo esto que tiene
que ver con el carisma la imagen y la
memoria que queda de la reina isabel
segunda que por siete décadas ha
iniciado los destinos del reino unido y
ahora su hijo que ha estado casi por el
mismo tiempo lo cierto preparándose para
hacer monarca y ha llegado al momento y
que tiene que salir escena y tratar de
probar es que puede llevar a la
monarquía británica el siglo 21 con la
misma gracia y con la misma eficiencia
que lo hizo sumado si el otro de los
temas de los que se habla es de la
posibilidad de que algunos países de la
commonwealth podrían buscar desligarse
de la monarquía británica es una
posibilidad real
bueno siempre es una posibilidad real de
hecho sin ir más lejos hace unos meses
atrás barbados era un cómodo 4 grado se
terminó transformando en república en
jamaica hay una tendencia anti monarquía
importante en el actual gobierno que sí
está ya pero por ejemplo en países como
nueva zelanda australia canadá que son
los doctorados más grandes y los más
importantes pareciera que los aires
antiguo marquistas no toman tracción
como siempre rodrigo puede ser una
posibilidad y como estos son países
independientes pero que conservan algún
arca británico como su jefe de estado
están ligados al reino unido- de esta
manera pero
perfectamente el pueblo de estos países
podría decidir
y desligarse lo cierto de esta desunión
sin perjuicio de eso y yo creo que esta
la circunstancias actuales y por lo
menos en el corto plazo no están las no
están las condiciones para que eso
ocurra si volviendo al discurso de este
viernes carlos ha nombrado a su hijo
william ya la esposa de éste a kate como
príncipes de gales el mismo título que
tuvieron tanto él como la princesa
diana- más allá de lo simbólico que
implica este nombramiento para los
nuevos príncipes
bueno a mí me llamó la atención lo
rápido que se decantó eso lo mismo
también el nombramiento de la reina
camila ahora no cierto como reina
consorte ahora respecto a lo de tu
pregunta bueno a ver en primer lugar que
establece inmediatamente quienes en su
legítimo sucesor a pesar de que eso ya
está establecido en el orden de sucesión
de la corona británica pero como tú bien
señalaba es un símbolo en un símbolo
relevante en segundo lugar y lo dijo el
mismo rey carlos en su discurso el oso
durante buena parte de su día del título
de príncipe de gales y lo confía ese
título la responsabilidad es que ya
ellos ellos llevan lo cierto a su hijo
william eventualmente tendrá que haber
esa una ceremonia investidura como la
que he recibido en la década de los 60
de parte de su madre pero nuevamente
eso para por verse y por otro lado yo
creo que también hay que tomar en
consideración
de alguna manera está que estos estos
signos que afectarlos de querer
establecer meridiana y claramente
quiénes son las personas más cercanas a
su figura de entre la familia real y de
ahí entonces
la investidura en los otros como
príncipe y princesa de gales de sb y
yerno en su casa